I stole
$163,000 on my house I think my net
worth is zero Once you pull the equity
out of the house get rid of the house
debt sell off all my collectibles and
pay off all my debts I think that puts
me at $0 I'm worthless the documentary
was really good frankly I watched the
whole damn thing it's an hour long I
wanted it to be longer I thought it was
so good and I thought the guy who made
the documentary is Mega talented he
really did a a really good piece of film
I don't know I'm very impressed I mean
he really spent time out there with him
he really immersed himself in Boogie's
world so this guy Mike clom was with him
for 9 months and he had full access to
his day-to-day schedule personal
contacts and financial statements I know
Boogie is probably doing it just for the
attention but it is kind of admirable
that he gave him that level of
transparency right in in the service of
making a good documentary so here is
Boogie talking about how his net worth
is zero